Aquaman was directed by James Wan and
stars Jason Momoa as Arthur curry and in
this film he discovers that he is the
rightful heir to the underwater Kingdom
called Atlantis and he must fight or
also known as the ocean master played by
Patrick Wilson because he also wants
that Kingdom under his rule
I've been following James wants career
for a really long time ever since saw
insidious the conjuring I think he's one
of the most talented directors working
today I've always been so excited to see
him get bigger and better gigs I think
he's great and so I was really curious
to see how he would bring Aquaman to the
big screen because this superhero
doesn't necessarily have the same
reputation as some of the more iconic
ones that we know today for a while he
was kind of a joke and it's been more
recent comics that have made the
character a lot more badass and more
entertaining and so I was curious to see
how they would handle this this is a
very self-aware film that's knowingly
silly that's purposefully over-the-top
that throws everything at the screen in
a gigantic explosion of underwater
festivities and so much color and pure
enjoyment and fun that I couldn't help
but smile through most of Aquaman I
think this is a really entertaining
movie and I am very surprised to say
that because the trailers didn't really
impress me they looked like a bit of a
mess I was concerned about overuse of
CGI but I have to say please all the
visual effects designers have worked on
this film pat yourself on the back
because the work that's on display here
is so incredibly impressive it's a
beautiful movie I mean yeah a lot of it
is CG you can't make this movie without
CG but there were times where it
reminded me of Avatar just how colorful
it was how beautiful everything looked
the the ocean creatures and the costume
design everything just leaps off the
screen it's such a bright and vivid
looking movie and Jason Momoa is perfect
casting here I really can't imagine
anyone else as this character having
seen him as Arthur curry he's clearly
relishing every minute he has on screen
he brings so much physicality to the
action scenes which James Wan has taken
a very unique approach to all of the
hand-to-hand combat scenes and
the underwater battles were surprisingly
unique looking all the fight scenes are
in great wide shots you can see
everything that's going on and I think
this is some of my favorite action I've
seen in the DC Universe so far James Wan
did a great job helming these action
scenes and honestly for a film that I
wasn't really anticipating all that much
from I found myself really enjoying how
purposefully silly this movie was I said
to my friends when it ended I was like
that felt like anime that felt like a
Saturday morning on Toonami watching
Dragon Ball Z it's really loud and big
there is no holding back people flex
their muscles and scream and shout
declarations of Valor shouting whoo
their names are and over-the-top poses
and everything like it's it's really out
there and some people are going to look
at that and say well that's
cringe-worthy that was horrible that
would that was just really dumb like
they're gonna compare it to other films
that have tried to be a lot more over
the top and say well they didn't really
understand what those films need and
this is one of those movies where I can
actually completely understand that like
I saw it with four people and a couple
of us were like yeah and then the other
two were like okay I actually really
like that so it could polarize fans a
little bit but I feel like it's one of
those movies where I can completely
understand if you think this movie is
just so bad that it's funny but my
retort to that is that the craft that's
on display the action sequences the
visual effects the colors the musical
score everything is really well done and
so I can't help but think that James Wan
was trying to make a cheesy 80s cartoon
he cast Dolph Lundgren in the film for
God's sakes he knows what he's doing he
is purposefully making a film that is so
self-aware that embraces its inner
Thundercats or Sailor Moon or all of
those really cheesy cartoons that so
many people actually really love and if
you can accept that and appreciate that
and understand that that's really what
they're going for because one has said
that an interview
that he wanted to make a very fun movie
that knew exactly what it was and that
put everything on the screen on purpose
to assault you with this over the I mean
an octopus plays the fucking drums okay
they knew what they were doing and it's
all the better for it I looked over at
my buddy when we were watching and I was
laughing but not like laughing at it it
was just like they really did that they
really did that that's fucking hilarious
and a lot of that really made me happy
but there's gonna be a lot of people who
won't look at it like that they're not
gonna see that and they're just gonna
think it's really poorly done but if
you're the type of person who loves
cheesy 80s cartoons or anime from that
period like very shown in anime like
Ronin warrior type stuff here okay
there's a lot of yelling and there's a
lot of really macho testosterone muscley
stuff like if it wasn't underwater
they'd all be covered in baby oil that's
the type of movie that James Wan made
here and I really appreciated that
unfortunately sometimes the narrative
and the pacing suffer as a result it's
never a slow film and when I say pacing
I don't always mean that oh this scene
is boring or this scene isn't fast
enough for this scene is too fast
sometimes it just means that scenes
aren't structured as properly as they
could be it is a film that sometimes
feels like we're going to this place to
get this thing all right we got that
let's go to this place to get this thing
okay now we have that let's go here
there's a very Indiana Jones type feel
to it you feel sometimes like you aren't
really watching a story so much as a
really entertaining series of scenes
there's also some D aging makeup early
on with a character that was so
noticeable that it really took me out of
almost every scene this person was in
and it really bugged me because there's
so many emotional scenes early on that
are supposed to really hook you into the
heartfelt part of this film and I was
just looking at a play-doh guy there's
also a major attempt to get deep into
the backstory of Aquaman when he was a
younger kid and it feels so quick and so
incredibly rushed and pushed to the side
I just think that the first act of the
movie was a
ruff it starts to pick up its pace and
get a lot more entertaining once the
main mission starts so to speak and
towards the end everything is just
flying left and right this is now the
fifth time that Patrick Wilson has
worked with James Wan after the two
conjuring and two insidious films they
obviously have a great working
relationship together and he does a
pretty good job in the movie the
character could have been a lot more
fleshed out though he's a very cliched
villain he wants to throne
Aquaman is the rightful heir they were
gonna clash and okay you know I'll say
this though like the the conclusion for
those characters actually did surprise
me but his character's motivation was
just something we've seen a thousand
times before as a physical presence
though he was great like I actually felt
that he could kick the shit out of
Aquaman if he wanted to and their
sequences where he does
I also liked how Aquaman wasn't perfect
in this movie like he loses a lot of
battles some people are gonna hate the
way this movie turned out they are going
to zero in on the really cheesy aspects
of it and say that's bad I wanted a more
serious Aquaman and some people who
don't give a shit about Aquaman are just
gonna look at it and say that's really
silly and dumb and it's bad I have to
disagree purely because I feel like
that's exactly what they're trying to
make and I love that I love a bunch of
people that get together and
purposefully make a Saturday morning
cartoon with this insane budget and all
of these actors who are going for it on
screen the visual effects are just
absolutely stunning it does however have
a lot of narrative and pacing issues
it feels very rushed at times and
sometimes it's a bit too slow in regards
to what it does
there are backstories that don't always
come to full arc and sometimes they feel
like they were forgotten or thrown away
and there is some really noticeable
de-aging CGI that takes you out of the
movie early on and the first act
definitely had some narrative and
structure issues but the movie saves
itself continuously with insanely good
action sequences and a really fun
performance by Jason Momoa I'm gonna
give Aquaman a be I want to see this
movie again purely because there's a
laser sharks in it
I don't know what else you could
possibly want in life I mean that's what
dr. evil wanted for a long time and
Aquaman gave it to us
I enjoyed the film I'm curious to know
what other people think about it thank
you so much guys for watching and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]